[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen weintreff
welt meine freunde zum ende der letzten
episode haben wir diese dumme schüssel
hier geld im ozean
result wieder ich habe auf jeden fall
geangelt in der letzten episode zum
ersten mal so richtig und habe diese
schüssel minute angel deswegen brauche
ich die eigentlich nicht aber dann
nämlich seit wir mit was wir auf jeden
fall auch unter die letzte episode in
die kommentare geschrieben wurde war das
hier luca ist es niemals schaffen sich
innerhalb von nur zwei folgen auf das
ende vorzubereiten deswegen meine lieben
freunde habe ich für heute mir gedacht
suchen wir einfach schon mal das end
portal
ich weiß die begeisterung hält sich in
grenzen die sache ist allerdings dass
ich mich wirklich schon ein bisschen
auch vorbereiten möchte wir sind in
folge 89 in zehn folgen jetzt die letzte
folge von daher werde ich zuallererst
mir erstmal hier den lohnstopp
rausnehmen und den browsern auch
mitnehmen denn das wird mir auch und in
die kommentare geschrieben ihr wisst ja
ich bin immer sehr aktiv in den
kommentaren also wenn auch ihr tipps und
ratschläge oder vorschläge habt schreibt
sie auch gern und bin ein wie wollt ihr
mich geschrieben luca nimm dir
einfach den geistlichen also ein
williger und
handel mit ihm dann bekommst du die
ender perlen und ich glaube ich habe ja
sogar nur wie viele in japan hatte ich
irgendwie fünf oder sechs oder so in
meiner kiste schon einmal ganz kurz nach
ich habe nur sechs sender perlen und
wenn ich diese sechs länder perlen mal
ganz gut sichtbar zeigen hier mit
lohnstopp rein packe dann an ich kann
sogar noch ein lohnstopp nehmen kann
muss ich gar nicht wenn die hülle das
wollte ich ja nicht auch erst machen
dann habe ich auf jeden fall solche ende
augen und diese ende augen kann ich
neue rezepte
ich kann jetzt auf jeden fall soll ende
august in die luft schmeißen an
danke du mich auch darüber informiert in
die richtung ist auf jeden fall unser
stronghold also dass
da jetzt nicht dies weg
oder
so dass schon jedes mal wenn wir eine
werfen dies bot jetzt allerdings meine
lieben freunde sind dass sie die ende
augen das sind quasi ender perlen so ein
bisschen auf steroiden wir können die
einfach mehr richtung schmeißen oder
irgendwo hinschmeißen und die zeigen uns
wo das end portal ist also das portal wo
wir schlussendlich in diesem projekt hin
wollen und ich brauche der engländer
perlen und damit ich nicht die ganze
zeit ändern töten muss ja wirklich sehr
stark sind euch ja schon den ein oder
anderen tod in diesem projekt mit zu
verzeichnen habe ich mir auf jeden fall
gedacht mir geschrieben erholt in den
geistlichen da kann es mit ihm traden
klar kann ich jetzt auf meine insel da
hinten gehen davon
die villa insel allerdings haben die
alle schon im beruf die sind ja
teilweise schon fischer bibliothekar und
schmid und keine ahnung was da habe ich
mir gedacht fahren wir einfach mal
wieder in unserer über wasser dorf und
geben dort einem dem beruf geistlichen
von euch eine ganz kurze time lab
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde da sind wir
jetzt auch schon angekommen hier in
unserem villiger dorf auf dem wasser
dennoch hier blöde löcher überall im
fußboden na ja die sind wir auf jeden
kann ja nichts führen die nicht
schwimmen können die sache ist das
theoretisch der hier hat keinen beruf
aber das wird ein bisschen stressig ihn
herauszuholen von der schau ich mal hier
hinten der auch kein beruf dann können
wir ihnen auf jeden fall zu einem
geistlichen verwandeln und ihr seht doch
schon ich hab mir acta und gold
mitgenommen habe ich mich ein bisschen
informiert in minecraft vigier und habe
mir gedacht mensch so muss ich mit den
handel so
chris ging fix ok perfekt da kommt auch
schon an und wir bekommen redstone
brauche ich zwar nicht weil sie müssen
ja auch nur ein bisschen hoch traden von
daher hier nochmal ein bisschen ich
nehme jetzt mal meine smaragd glocke und
verwandelt die kurzes markt wir haben
zweieinhalb sechs markt also wenn das
nicht klappen sollte jetzt gleich dann
weiß ich auch nicht mehr wir haben es
auf jeden fall und er müsste sich genau
jetzt schon verwandeln und müsste dann
von der stufe lehrling über wandern zu
ende jetzt ist ein lehrling ok perfekt
und jetzt nämlich schon das goldangebot
und ich weiß nicht wohin mit meinem
ganzen gold deswegen jetzt einfach mal
ganz kurz ein bisschen gold hier traden
da kriechen pass märkte wieder
zurücknehme mein gott wieder raus und er
verwandelt sich jetzt als nächstes
wieder nicht zu einem lehrling sondern
zum gesellen glaube ich hoffe ich mal
und es ist ein geselle perfekt das heißt
wir können uns was können wir unseren
sondern ein bisschen glos doch mal
gönnen kommen die kaufen ein bisschen
kloster unternehmen wir mal noch ein
bisschen redstone mit würde ich sagen
davon hat er jetzt allerdings sie mal am
start von daher müssen wir wirklich bei
brawn bleiben also können wir uns hier
noch ein bisschen kloster haben das
jetzt am start und jetzt müsste er schon
meister werden glaube ich und
dementsprechend auch schon mit uns die
ender perlen handeln können wir schauen
mal und er hat die ender perlen am start
perfekt und erzählen die verringertes
angebot mit nur vier stück und ich
benötige auch ich habe sechs ich
benötige zwölf stück also benötige ich
insgesamt diese anfang an perlen ich
glaub ihnen noch ein paar mehr ab wir
haben so vieles mag ich weiß nicht wohin
damit und ich glaube lieber zu viel als
zu wenig haben von daher kann ich jetzt
hier die ganzen nochmal weiter starten
und mir daraus jetzt zwölf stück mache
und ein bisschen ender perlen behalte
ich einfach mal fürs ende weil es
natürlich auch sein kann dass der
erfahrungs flächen verkauft auch
[Musik]
in appellen sind jetzt aber ausverkauft
ach guck mal wie viel kriegen jetzt
durch die neuen stück abgekauft wir
haben 35 level und ich bin jetzt level
das war der dümmste kauft den ich je
gemacht habe
[Musik]
du bist wie sonnen verkäufer irgendwie
der türkei am strand mit so viel zu
lange sakko der ebenso 10 rolex verkauft
zehn jahre gehören die zehn jahre
garantie
ja dann gib mir die erfahrung zurück
aber gut meine lieben freunde ich kann
auf jeden fall meinen brauchst an die
wieder mit neben den geistlichen lasse
ich einfach mal hier ich nehme jetzt
nicht mehr auf meine innere des wifi zum
großer akt mit dem boden und so weiter
und so fort die sache ist allerdings wir
können sie ja auch jemand hätten mit dem
ende augen meine insel ist da hinten
falls ihr euch die tablets genug bist du
dass das heißt das auge müsste auch so
in die richtung fliegen ich schmeiße es
mal hoch und es
[Musik]
ach so es
gibt wasser mehrere and portale weil es
nur sinn gemacht hätte dass die ender
perle bzw das ende auge in diese
richtung geflogen wären wir müssen uns
jetzt auf jeden fall ein bisschen freuen
euch noch eine ganz kurze time lab wie
ich es hoffentlich vom sonnenuntergang
nach hause schaffen
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde da sind wir auch
schon wieder an unserer insel hier
angekommen guck mal habe ich letztes mal
schon provisorischen bot gepackt ich
sehe da vorne auch direkt mit einem baby
ich weiß nicht ob ich vom boot aus
schießen kann ja kann ich auf jeden fall
so sagt er ist tot jetzt einmal ganz
kurz die parken und hoffen dass sie
nicht noch weitere monster sind ich will
jetzt nicht das noch in den letzten
folgen jemals in luft fliegt der
leuchtturm ist auf jeden fall angegangen
ich habe in der timeline das hat mir
wahrscheinlich gesehen kurz geguckt ob
ich nicht irgendwie ein bett mit dabei
haben leute 2 kassiert
und leute 2 max hier
[Musik]
wir haben es auf jeden fall hinter uns
meine lieben freunde die nacht ist
vorbei ich wusste dass wieder irgendwas
passieren wird aber ich bin noch ganz
ehrlich wir hatten lange keine krieg bei
mir am start und es wäre natürlich schön
gewesen wenn er da hinten am kreuz der
einzige gewesen wäre aber wir haben
natürlich noch einen zweiten gab er
direkt vor unserer bude war hier wieder
alles kaputt gegangen perfekt kann ich
gleich noch mal neu
er ist halt kein platz mehr drauf hier
natürlich wieder die grobe erde drauf
und die beiden margeriten und jetzt
probiere ich es trotzdem mal mit dem
schild dass ich vielleicht irgendwie
hinkriege also ja ja
ist er gestorben kuh hielt für dann
schreibe ich hier jetzt einfach mal fuhr
noch mit dazu und an darunter
schildkröte von daher meine lieben
freunde eine schweigeminute die
verstorbenen tiere auf unserer insel das
hier vorne bei euch mal auch eben kurz
wieder neu auf ich weiß nicht mehr genau
wie das alles war wo genau erde war wo
gras war wo was anderes war adorno
allerdings können wir erstmal buchstein
hier so ein bisschen dafür benutzten
füllt den untergrund und dann hier
einfach erde drauf also ich glaube so
etwas war das auch aus hier vorne war
natürlich noch die laterne drauf und wir
hatten hier auch noch den bilderrahmen
wo eine fackel drin war und eine
bruchstein stufe glaube ich also sodann
eine fackel hier und da eine stufe
irgendwie hier rein so das hat mir auch
noch der wolke noch irgendwas mal
geschrieben mit irgendwas mann ambros
reinpacken soll dann gibt's noch mal
besser aus lassen wir jetzt erstmal so
erstmal warten bis das gras hierüber
wechsel haben dass auf jeden fall wieder
aufgebaut und jetzt können wir uns dann
tatsächlich auch darum kümmern dass wir
meine lieben freunde das ende suchen ich
sortiere hier gerade noch mal ein
bisschen meine items papier den ganzen
rats online.de nicht neu bekommen habe
es mag benötige ich auch erstmal nicht
mehr wir nehmen die ender perlen mit wir
nehmen uns selbst wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen bruchstein mit lohn staub lasse
ich erst mal noch hier den rest den
benötige ich erstmal nicht mehr meinen
brown stand partie auch erst mal hier
rein kann ich auch gleich wieder direkt
nach oben räumen glos dann brauche ich
auch erstmal nicht was er einmal immer
gut aber zwei stück ist einer zuviel
essen ist wichtig und die ende augen
natürlich um es gleich zu finden und
dann nehme ich mir jetzt auch noch mal
hat die bruchsteine habe ich ein schild
habe ich nehme mir auch noch mal das
totem der unsterblichkeit mit und pack
das über in die linke hand anstatt mein
schild dass wenn ich sterbe dass sich
dort dann auf jeden fall ja
wiedergeboren werde und ich nehme mir
auch ein bett mit das wort nimmt in die
kommentare geschrieben da wird nämlich
gesagt luca wenn du aus dem song hold
raus gehst bzw wenn du das stationäre
bevor du uns ende gehst jetzt auf jeden
fall ein bett vor das portal so dass du
dort einfach wieder response wenn du
getötet wir es nicht dann wieder dahin
laufen musst du deine ganzen items dies
bauen und zwei transport als auch danke
dir dafür den kommentar generell danke
für eure ganzen tipps und hinweise und
wir meine lieben freunde werden uns
jetzt zum ende bewegen ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich werde mich heute noch nicht
richtig in der stronghold rein wagen
denn allein der ort um zu dem and port
zu kommen ist schon furcht einflößend
genug ist schon gefährlich genug und da
habe ich mir gedacht wir fahren dorthin
es mit der anscheinend irgendwo dahinten
sein wir fahren dorthin und wenn ich
dort bin ich
ein bisschen holz mitnehmen doch niemals
einfach mal hier noch ein halbes deck
eichenstämme mit und ich werde auch
meinen crafting table mitnehmen so dass
ich mir sachen kräften kann was ich von
sagen wollte war meine lieben freunde
ich werde dort heute
ich weiß genau dass balu will dass ich
ihn mitnehmen weil und ich sind auf
jeden fall auf dem weg in richtung ende
beziehungsweise weiß ich gar nicht ob
die richtung ist also ich würde sagen
dass wir noch mal ganz kurz die vorne
halten und ich meine appelle hoch und
dann schauen wir ob ich wirklich über
den ozean drüberfahren muss also war
ganz kurzen ende auge nehmen hoch
schmeißen und es geht in die richtung
meiner lieben freunde ganz schnell
deswegen natürlich wieder aufsammeln ihr
fragt euch wahrscheinlich lukas sammelst
du dir alle wieder auf du hast zwölf
stück ist doch riesig ich muss die in
das portal reinstecken also in dem and
poor tal sind so rahmen und da müssen
diese ende augen rein und das ist 3 x 3
x 3 x 3 also insgesamt 43 also zwölf
stück deswegen sollten diese zwölf
stücke auf jeden fall ausreichend sei
denn ich verliere eine dann wenn es blöd
aber ich bin guten mutes dass wir das
hinkriegen unser nächster stopp ist
diese kleine insel vorher seien da
spreche ich noch meine hoch dann guckt
man in welche richtung wir müssen ob
vielleicht dann nach links oder nach
rechts und was ich auch wohin sagen
wollte war ich werde das heutige video
bin ich schon mal ganz ehrlich muss ich
euch auch schon sagen das heutige video
werde ich beenden wenn ich an dem ort
bin wo ich mich runter graben muss
industrial reinen das möchte in der
nächsten episode machen dann möchte ich
eine komplett eigene episode machen denn
ich benötige da wirklich noch mal eure
tipps ob es irgendwelche genauen
vorgehensweisen gibt okay wir müssen
wirklich übers wasser ob irgendwelche
guten vorgehensweisen gibt wie man da
irgendwie vorgehen soll ob man irgendwie
sich so und so bewegen sollte ob es da
und da irgendwelche tipps gibt im sinne
von hey wenn an der wand zwei
cobblestone blöcke sind dann heißt es
dahinter ist das portal von daher könnte
mir jetzt schon mal gern und in die
kommentare schreiben was dich beachten
muss wenn ich in der folge die
übermorgen online geht in das strom holt
reingehe also in diese cent gefängnis da
unten allerdings leben wir jetzt gerade
im hier und jetzt und müssen uns erst
mal darauf konzentrieren dass wir dieses
ende überhaupt finden es kann ja sein
dass das noch extrem weit entfernt ist
deswegen balloon erstmal hier raus bzw
ich brauche mal einfach ganz großartig
hängen wieder fest ich brauch mal immer
ganz kurz mein brötchen hier ab dass wir
perfekt weiterlaufen können so dass
nicht direkt wieder mit und ab nach oben
balu kommt natürlich auch mit ich hoffe
er schafft es bis an land zu kommen ist
immer ein bisschen lamarche unterwegs
perfekte teleportiert sich einfach von
daher jetzt mal wieder eine ende perle
geschmissen sie geht immer noch in diese
richtung also es ist wirklich so dass
unser stronghold anscheinend sich in
unserer region hier vorne befindet die
hatten wir auch schon interessante
erfahrungen gemacht hier vorne auf dem
eis und dann mit wallufer als sich auch
noch auf dem boot wie wir da oben
gefahren sind das war nicht der fall ich
weiß jetzt nicht genau ich glaube sie
sind diese richtung hergeflogen etwa
deswegen laufen bereits erstmal ein
bisschen weiterhin und schmerzen hier
auf dem hügel die nächste ender
perlewitz messeende auges verwächst
nicht einmal so ein bisschen weiter in
diese richtung freunde also in den wald
oben rein war auch wieder klar dass es
spannungs mäßig genau jetzt in richtung
nacht sich zu eignet und die sonne so
langsam untergeht was hätte auch anders
sein sollen und daher hier gekonnt
hochspringen balu es noch immer
weil hinter mir
war lewis hinter mir perfekt weiter
geht's freunde da hinten haben wir
dieses bikes nähe dessen bäume schmeißt
man hier noch mal ganz kurz ein es geht
immer noch weiter in den wald rein ich
weiß nicht wie weit ich hier noch laufen
muss bitte lande nicht auf einem baum ok
perfekt und weiter in den wald rein ihn
nacht bricht an ich bin gespannt ob wir
es heute überhaupt finden werden ich
weiß nicht mehr wie weit von stronghold
weg ist ich glaube ich habe noch nie so
richtig in minecraft projekt von mir
überhaupt das ende besucht aus das waren
vielleicht multiplayer projekt ich weiß
es nicht so genau die sonne geht auf
jeden fall so langsam unter ich bin froh
dass ich im bett mitgenommen habe wir
haben
[Musik]
die brauche jetzt nicht
ist das jetzt hier
also eigentlich war das doch nur
unterirdisch oder okay es geht wirklich
noch weiter in die richtung also das war
es noch nicht
[Musik]
wir sind auf jeden fall auch freunde vom
band ihr habt gerade in der luft gesehen
freunde dass die ender perle hier nicht
geblockt ist und wieder runter zu mir
gegangen sondern sie ist kaputt gegangen
das heißt an diesem ort meine lieben
freunde befindet sich das ende des
projekts minecraft mit luca wir müssen
hier auf jeden fall runter gehen
allerdings würde ich an der stelle die
heutige episode minecraft mit luca jetzt
erst mal beenden es hat unfassbar viel
spaß macht die heutige episode weil wir
wieder viele neue sachen entdeckt haben
die sonne geht gerade unter ich lass mal
ganz kurz hier sitzen und schlafe auch
so dass wir in der nächsten folge dann
direkt in einen neuen tag starten können
es ist wundervoll hiermit den
polarlichtern und so ich hatte das
selber immer zur mitte des projekts
eingestellt dass wir hier so geile
lichter am himmel haben aber gut meine
lieben freunde wir sehen uns genau hier
übermorgen wieder ich hoffe ihr seid
wieder mit dabei über morgen 20 uhr und
dann werden wir uns runter graben zum
ende ist übermorgen jesse
[Musik]